hello america mark levine and this is
life liberty and levin
this is a different kind of program
where i do these long-form interviews
uh sometimes we're focused like a laser
on breaking news
and we're going to do some of that
tonight but i also want to use
this program to give additional voice
to individuals who i think are
exceptionally intelligent
fairly young and can have and will have
an influence
on the future of the country i think
it's my
job as i get older and older and older
to make sure we have people coming up
behind us
who have an opportunity to be heard now
two of these
gentlemen who are on with us tonight
have had an opportunity to be heard
but not necessarily in a form like this
dave rubin of the reuben report
he wrote that great book don't burn this
book
charlie kirk turning point usa founder
he wrote a great book the maga doctrine
so i want to talk to them
i hope they'll influence additional
young people and i think this is the way
that we try to address the culture
uh in as many platforms as we possibly
can
dave rubin how are you my friend mark
i'm glad to be with you
and uh you know if you would have told
me a few years ago that i'd be on the
mark levin show
saying that he's a guy that blazed the
trail for a you know a liberal like me
i don't know what i would have made of
that but but here we are
and i told you right before we started i
normally i live in la for some strange
reason i'm i'm down on vacation in
florida the only guy i would have put a
jacket on for so here we go
thank you thank you dave rubin you
weren't always
a sort of libertarian slash conservative
uh in fact you were a progressive for
much of your uh
young career tell us what happened why
you
decided wait a minute maybe these guys
on the other side make more sense and
you eventually
sort of moved over to what i call
classical liberalism
or the liberty agenda what was it that
caused you to do that
sure you know i do still consider myself
even now a classical liberal and don't
burn this book was
my way of laying out all of my
classically liberal principles that as
you're
sort of implying in in a modern sense
makes you
a moderate conservative or a libertarian
and we can always whittle around what
those issues are and where the
government
should be involved or not be involved or
things like that but yes i was a bernie
supporting lefty you can find videos of
me five or six years ago supporting
bernie believe it or not
there were there were several reasons
for that one of the things i talk about
in the book is that i think if you grow
up
in an american public education system
and getting the american
culture the american the things that
fall within the overton window of what's
acceptable
in america you're everyone is sort of a
default lefty you have to come
to conservatism you have to come to
libertarianism you have to come to the
idea of individual rights
and freedom and liberty and all the
things that you've been writing about
and talking about
for so many years so you sort of if you
just grow up
you're just kind of a lefty it's sort of
like oh democrats are nice
republicans are mean liberals care about
poor people
conservatives care about money democrats
are for peace
republicans are for war now these are
all silly factory setting
ideas that once you dig a little deeper
you find
are not true and then i had a series of
events about five years ago
that caused my wake up and i would say i
have no problem being called a
conservative at this point
just to be very clear what what really
is so beautiful about
the conservative movement right now is
it is an extremely
wide tent you know what's happening on
the left is basically it's it's you're
woke or you're out meaning if you don't
select these 10 things that the woke
people want and you have to do it the
second they want you to do it then
you're out well what that does is
it creates incredible opportunity for
people on the right to say hey
you know we've got some sort of
traditional conservative
religious republicans let's say we've
got more libertarian minded people we've
got hardcore mega people
we have more uh you know either neocons
or more generic republicans
that's a pretty wide swath of people and
i would say i fall a little more on the
libertarian side of that
and that's a great place to have
interesting debates and what i find is
when i go
to you just mentioned charlie kirk when
i go to turning point events
i talk about some things that i know
that the average conservative may not
agree with
and guess what they say hey we're happy
you're here and let's keep discussing it
usually what they say with a smile on
their faces
hey we'll get you eventually but they're
down to have the debate where there
really is no debate on the other side
well let me ask you about this let me
ask you about the other side
even when you were quote unquote with
the other side
was it as totalitarian my word was it as
totalitarian as we see it today that is
anti-free speech anti-choice in all
things but abortion
uh anti-intellectualism um
anti-so much that is important in a free
society
was it that way five or ten years ago
no it wasn't and and i think you know
that and i think even though most of
your audience is obviously conservative
and libertarian i think they know it too
let's not forget
the aclu that was a liberal
free speech organization they fought
so that the neo-nazis could march in
skokie illinois the famous case that
everyone knows about in 1971 where they
went to illinois
neo-nazis wanted to march and it was a
place where i think the the
most highest percentage of holocaust
survivors lived in the united states and
the aclu defended their right to do it
of course and it's it's an offensive
thing
but these were liberals defending the
right of free expression and free speech
even when it's hard to do which is the
only time that it matters
to defend free speech everyone says
they're for free speech but then
something weird happens
and then and then they don't do it
something happened
what happened to the jfk liberal what
happened to ask not what your country
can do for you
ask what you can do for your country i
mean really think about that statement
jfk who was a liberal democrat
although he did want to get out of wars
which is now not something democrats
want to do and he also did want to
reduce taxes which is certainly
not something democrats today want to do
but ask not what your country can do for
you ask what you can do for your country
that is
180 degrees absolute opposite
of what bernie and all of the democrats
including joe biden
say now they say oh we can give you this
we will give you this for free
we will artificially raise this wage you
will get free education you will get
free health care
and that's the reverse of actually what
true liberalism is
so for me it's sort of a debate on do i
want to keep trying to
save the word liberalism and show people
that classical liberals
are are actually modern conservatives or
do i just want to say hey
i'm a conservative now that's more of a
semantic argument but no
liberals were not always like this the
woke totalitarian
progressive ideology that has now
destroyed almost all of our cultural
institutions our educational
institutions certainly our political
institutions
it that is a relatively new phenomenon
that was brewing at the academic level
and then it just burst forth into
society
i was warning about it for a couple
years and people kept saying to me no no
when these kids get out of college the
real world that'll set them straight
and unfortunately that's not how it's
worked out you pointed out earlier
you know the default position is
liberalism or i guess now we would say
leftism
uh when you come through the public
education system
and you've got the teachers union which
is really quite radical
um and much of the propaganda that goes
on in these classrooms
uh but it's it's gotten to the point now
where we actually have
media outlets the majority media outlets
trying to crush a minority of media
outlets that have different opinions we
have big tech now
that we all had hope would be the
competitive part
against big media which is now thrown in
with big media and thrown in with one
party
uh what do you think's happened here
mark we have an extraordinary fight
right now you know the founders could
have never imagined a structure
that existed above the government so
when they wanted to limit the power of
the government they didn't think that
giant corporations that could control
all of our information and our ability
to communicate
and to actually assemble information and
our ability
to talk to other people you know the
public square that now exists
online that once existed in the in the
public square of your town
they couldn't have envisioned that there
would be something so powerful
so they put all of the systems in place
the beautiful systems of the united
states of checks and balances and
branches of government and all of these
things
but they couldn't have imagined this and
because of that it has put us at a very
perilous
place where look it doesn't matter what
you think about donald trump it doesn't
matter what you think about
january 6th or anything else on one
given day
a bunch of tech oligarchs decided to
eliminate
the digital life of donald trump they
booted him from youtube from facebook
from twitter from spotify so he can't
listen to music and from pinterest
so he can't post uh apple pie recipes or
whatever they're doing on
over there that's a scary proposition
and then as you correctly point out when
you when you completely
solidify that with a political ideology
when you say okay well what what is woke
is acceptable
but if you say that there are two
genders that's not acceptable
or if you say you're for low taxes
that's not acceptable because they'll
tell you you're racist because somehow
that means you don't want to
help black people they've created a very
very narrow set of things that it's okay
to say
and this is a very tough one for those
of us that are libertarian minded
because do you want the government to
now come in
and break up these companies i mean joe
biden and the democrats are in charge of
the government so do you want the
government
to now fix fix you should use quotes
there
do you want the government big
government to fix a big tech
problem well then to me you'd have a
bigger problem i believe in human
ingenuity i i believe in competition
i started a tech company in the midst of
this called locals.com
uh it's just one part of the solution
and by the way there's no perfect
solution for everyone out there that
wants the perfect solution
it doesn't exist yet we saw what amazon
did to parlor servers
everyone knows about that so there's
there's big problems across the board
but you know david beat goliath so
i believe anything is possible but
here's the thing
is it really a free market when five or
six
of these massive multi-billionaires with
their massive
reach sucking the american people for 20
years
use their data to become enormously
powerful and rich
use their power in congress to get
protection under that rule 230
then when you have a small entrepreneur
like parlor trying to compete
they say okay for a variety of pretexts
we're going to crush you
and we're all going to do it together
and we're going to make sure you have no
way out
i don't think that's adam smith
capitalism i think that's more like
vladimir putin
capitalism and and on top of that
they have politicized themselves so
they're it's not just that they're in
the
capitalist market now they're using
their muscle
which they got in part thanks to
government to put
not just their finger on the scale of
politics but to put their entire weight
on the scale of politics to influence
the outcome of elections and they really
don't even make any
bones about it i mean it's it's pretty
obvious to all
and i agree with your point this is
rather perplexing
because what do we do about this when
you have one party that really has
control over most of the bureaucracy
whether republicans are in office or not
uh
are they really expected or capable of
controlling an entity like this or are
they going to further empower an enemy
an enemy like this it's a big problem
but let me ask you this
are the republicans really up to
fighting this i i watched them
david rubin and this is the question i
want to ask you when we come back for
the next segment
i watch them and sometimes i think to
myself other than a handful
most of them have no idea what's
swirling around they have no idea
of the ideology that they face they have
no idea
how that ideology has devoured so much
of the culture and they go on like
corporatists or they go on with the
business of government or whatever that
means
as if none of this is happening so that
is the predicate that i want to
lay for you when we come back the next
segment we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back america i'm with dave rubin
here of the reuben report
don't burn this book was a great book
that he wrote still is
locals.com and i mention all that
because what dave is demonstrating and
we have a lot of young people
demonstrating this
what people like like me are trying to
do is you're developing especially can
your own
independent platform actually many
independent platforms
so you're not relying on one or two or
three big entities
and one day maybe you're not reliant on
any big entities
as the attack on parlor has demonstrated
so dave rubin
my concern is i'll just be blunt about
me the left is diabolical in many
respects
they don't want to play within the
constitution in many respects you have
joe biden signing over
50 executive orders and so forth like he
caesar
you've got the democrats in the house
and the senate
acting like they're the roman senate
they're off doing their own thing
they talk about the constitution but
they don't want to work within the
limits of the constitution they focus on
the courts how they want to change the
electoral system
they're still chasing donald trump and
the republicans seem to be
reacting if anything they seem to be on
their own glide path and i don't know
exactly where that glide path is going
what do you think yeah i think this is a
really great point
and it you know look we could both sit
here for 10 hours and talk about all of
the things that are wrong with the left
and and the ridiculous
big government programs and that very
little actual political
philosophy sits behind what they're
doing other than the accumulation of
power we can do that so i so i like this
question
because let's put that aside for a
moment you know as a new guy to let's
say
this broad conservative coalition there
are very few conservatives i find
inspiration from i'll give you two who i
suspect you like as well
which would be ted cruz and rand paul i
think they're out there
they've been talking about big tech
they're always warning about
surveillance and the ever-expanding
state they
both did a really nice job when we had
these hearings about big tech
but that being said and again i think
these are good decent men who are
working hard for the american people
let's not forget that nothing happened
after those big tech hearings you know
it's like
it's a bunch of theater that we did
before the election where everyone was
warning about
section 230 that you talked about
earlier and then no one actually
does anything so for me as someone
that's sort of new to this
side i want to see more people that know
how to fight
and i think that really was why so many
people
hated trump to the level that that they
did it wasn't about trump's
policies which were sort of all over the
place in terms of there was a lot of
conservative stuff but not everything
conservative there was definitely
big government and spending in there as
well but the reason they hated trump was
not because of the policies
it was because he showed people how to
fight
and there is nothing that the media and
the big tech companies
hate more and the democrats hate more
than someone who
actually will fight so i hope that he's
able
i hope that the idea of trump in a way
lasts far
longer than trump the man and any good
idea has to live beyond one man
but i hope the idea of hey fight fight
guys because we are running thin
the american experiment as our friend
dennis prager often calls it might be
coming to an end
the the worst ideas are here and they
are eliminating
all of the things that we've done so
well for 250 years so i want to see more
conservatives fight
and you raise a very very important
point let's take that point
it was donald trump who tried to get the
national defense authorization act
amended in order to address
that section 230. he said look
everyone's going to vote to fund the
defense department
republicans are going to vote the funded
defense department now you need a rider
this is what we have to do it's not
going to work independently on its own
and who votes against him
all the democrats and most of the
republicans and they override his veto
but your point is well harry showed them
how to do it
and they rejected it and now the same
many of the same republicans are
complaining about the attack on free
speech
about these big tech companies
interfering in elections on behalf of
democrats and leftists
and they have impart themselves to blame
because they were given an opportunity
to do something about it
and they refused in the few minutes we
have left donald trump
the effort now is really to destroy the
man and destroy the people who support
him
in my view there is absolutely no need
for
impeaching and then trying donald trump
as a private citizen and as i've
listened all week that the democrats
present their case basically in any
court
in western civilization 99
of what they're presenting would be
inadmissible has absolutely nothing to
do with the guilt or innocence of donald
trump and inciting an insurrection
in fact so much of the information is
exculpatory he was the one according to
his chief of staff
who offered 5 000 national guardsmen in
early july to washington d.c
which they didn't take them up on and so
many other
steps that were taken that raised
serious questions to me you have all
this preparedness in advance by these
thugs by these militant groups
the fbi was aware of it goes to the
terrorism task force nobody knows what
happened
the sergeant of arms of both houses of
congress are informed that they need to
bring in the national guard by the
former
now former uh chief of the capitol
police what did they do with that
information apparently nothing
well did they tell their bosses nancy
pelosi and mitch mcconnell we have no
idea
and so all the questioning ends because
the narrative
is baked in and to get answers to the
narrative that is
some of us want to know exactly what
took place and who exactly was involved
and exactly
how we deal with this but that's not
what's happening
here do you think that the left and the
media and the democrat party will be
successful
in their effort to extinguish the trump
uh movement the trump ideas and donald
trump himself
well look i i think your assessment is
totally correct that that's what this is
about
they want to destroy him further meaning
it's not enough that he's not
president it's not enough that he's not
on any of the big platforms
it's not enough that he can't get his
voice out there it's now can we actually
destroy this person can we make sure
he's never heard from again
and as i've often said related to this
you know when they're going for trump
they're really coming for you and what i
mean by you is they're coming for
everyone watching this show they're
saying oh do you have any counter
opinion
we will come to for you because look
what we can do to the man
who was the most powerful person in the
world
just a few weeks ago look how we can get
rid of him
you know the sad part about this is well
there's several sad parts but i would
say the primary sad part
is that the average person in america
wants nothing to do with this
i don't even think that a lot of the
democrats really want to do
this impeachment this post-impeachment
sham that you're right the trial has had
virtually nothing to do with
the words that he said or anything like
that i think most people
are thinking we got way bigger problems
we have economic problems we have
lockdown problems and covid problems
and so many more important things and
the fact that this is going to be voted
on
in in essence purely on party lines with
a couple
sort of you know half republicans
whatever you want to call them like mitt
romney
who will jump ship just so that the
media will be nice to him and you know
when we previously talked about the
republicans who need to fight
it's like what you usually get with
republicans is sort of these romney
republicans
or the lincoln project guys these people
who actually fight for no conservative
or right-leaning principle ever but they
get on the cable news shows they can go
on msnbc and get pat on the head
like a dog and then you know hand it a
little a little snack so they feel good
about themselves
so i think i think the idea of
fight must continue whether whether they
get trump on this or not and
obviously i'm not for that but whether
they get him or not the idea of fight
must
must continue i think you just coined a
phrase that i love
by half republicans that's a very very
good phrase
david rubin keep up the good work we
very much enjoy
your writing we very much enjoy your
broadcasting god bless you
mark you thank you so much if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell